Ziggy pig and silly seal was the first
feature I created for
Stanley at timely comics and it probably
was around 1941 sometime
oh well known as al Jeffy outside of the
comics industry I would say that every
person I talked to when I say we just
got a huge acquisition al Jeffy is
giving us his papers he created the mad
Folden and without exception everybody
knows who al Jeffy is the reason that I
decided to donate my archives to
Columbia is that this is one of the ways
I can give something back to the city of
New York which sheltered me when I
arrived and educated me and and gave me
everything that I've had ever since I
think the only more significant person
at mad than al is probably you know its
founder Harvey Kurtzman himself and so
for Al to come here it's just incredibly
exciting
he's been the longest-running constant
he's been doing the fold in for over 50
years now
I think the archives that I will provide
to Columbia will contain as much of the
preliminary work as I can pull together
this is really just volumes of misspent
youth this is all my work from humbug
magazine which is really a very valuable
collection al is best known for the fold
and I think everybody knows him best for
the fold and in addition he did he
created and did for many years snap the
answers to stupid questions
but beyond mad
al is a link to some of the very
earliest Golden Age comics because he
worked for Stanley in the very early
days on teen comic called Patsy Walker
he created a funny animal comic called
Ziggy pig and silly seal value that
researchers may find in my work is
really pretty academic it's a key
Hillview into this period of time that I
loved what the archives will provide I
think you know people can go to you know
the the collection of Mad fold ins that
came out a couple of years ago they can
go to his biography they can go to the
you know 60 years of the best of mad
that just came out last year but what
people don't necessarily see is how all
of this stuff comes into creation to see
the the steps that an artist whether
it's our or any other artist whose work
we collect the steps that they go
through in order to create the the item
that everybody's familiar with
great stuff